Florence n'est pas la casserole mais
plutôt le sabre laser qu'il manie coûte
projecteur à présent sur la pratique du
Ludosport à Tours mais vous les avez
peut-être aperçu cet été sur l'île
Balzac tient des fans de Star Wars et
bien pas seulement le sabre laser c'est
un sport avec ses codes et ses règles
même pour choisir la couleur du sable il
faut d'abord faire ses preuves voyez ce
reportage de Benjamin Vatel si on
faisait plus rapidement
de forme de combat au sabre laser on
pense immédiatement à la saga Star Wars
mais ici pas de science-fiction c'est un
sport à part entière avec ces techniques
et ses règles les gens pensent pas que
c'est un vrai sport qui est pas il pense
pas qu'il y a un socle pédagogique avec
des vraiment les techniques avec avec
des tenues avec des armes qui ont été
développées pour avec des accessoires
qui ont été développés et souvent les
gens vous faites mumuse avec des trucs
qui font de la lumière quoi avant de
combattre tout bon Maître Jedi doit
connaître son ép ée le sabre laser il se
constitue comme ça avec une partie lame
et une partie pommeau donc la lame elle
est en polycarbonate donc c'est une
matière très très résistante légèrement
flexible et surtout résistante et il y a
une LED à l'intérieur qui va projeter de
la lumière dans le sabre et un
haut-parleur avec une carte électronique
qui va détecter les mouvements et créer
des sons et des couleurs en fonction de
ce qui se passe agilité endurance
précision et explosivité sont requises
pour exceller en Ludosport l'objectif
est de réussir à toucher son adversaire
Édouard et Maxime sont les deux
instructeurs de l'Académie qui compte 24
licenciés ce qu'on apprend premier ça va
être les pas bien se positionner à
rester équilibré stable le sabre laser
implique le respect l'entraide et
l'esprit de camaraderie et permet aussi
de réaliser quelques rêves alors ce qui
m'a attiré d'abord c'était de pouvoir
faire du sabre laser parce que c'est un
rêve de gosse
les pratiquants doivent attendre trois
ans et valider leur compétences avant de
pouvoir choisir la couleur de leur sabre
chaque année les 5 académies françaises
envoient leurs meilleurs combattants
représenter le pays au tournoi
international le prochain aura lieu en
décembre à Paris que la force soit avec
eux